at hairspray to get your life together
I'm not touching
you got to tidy up sometimes you know
you got to keep tidy dude and I'm not
just talking about our beautiful
hairpiece I'm talking about below yapped
I'm not your nutsack oh yeah I'm talking
my body hair nut hair weiner hair hair
on your body yeah give it that Philly
fade give it that nice bald fade yeah
well me cornrow you're nuts you feel me
do something nice for yourself so do it
right do it right do it with manscape
redesign an electric trimmer their
lawnmower 2.0 has a skin safe talk not
technology so this trimmer it won't cut
your sack dude yeah don't be down there
with a switchblade you know you've been
up all night doing a couple grams or
whatever you break out a switchblade to
tidy up your patch don't be that
fricking bad here oh that's a bad idea
no you're not to bleed we Knick those
things they bleed and your nuts have
other people and them dude take care of
your body yeah they also got the crop
preserver which is a deodorant just like
your armpits before your nutsack yeah
you think you're nuts don't stink boy
hanging out with your wiener all day
you're an idiot yeah it turns off and
free shipping with the code cats at
manscape calm always use the right tools
for the job your balls will thank you
yeah you wouldn't take a cannon into a
painting contest at a children's school
would you use the right tools for the
job get 20% off and free shipping with
the code cats at manscape calm forget
about it that's clamps off with free
shipping up manscaped I just said it use
cats trying to keep the lights on it's
2019 I can't believe we can't do things
like paint our teeth and do unique
things to ourselves yeah I hear you man
I hear you I hear you know what's even
scarier than all that you know what's
that shopping for life insurance dude
that's how I'm gonna button this up the
idea of looking for life insurance is so
scary
oh man the other day I was looking for
something you just stopped right oh I
got so scared cuz it was life injury to
thank God for policy genius.com it's an
easy way to shop for life insurance
online in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers to find your best
price yep think about somebody think
about yourself all about dying yep it's
gonna happen so what we're saying his
policy G is baby yes once you apply the
policy Gene's team will handle
the paperwork and red tape all right yep
they make it so easy for home insurance
auto insurance disability insurance life
insurance death insurance here's the
thing don't be that creep that dies and
doesn't leave a couple of you know
couple gee dad or mom at or a stepmom
you know we're surprised the
ex-girlfriend with a couple grand you
know yeah don't yeah yeah me still half
of her [ __ ] brought job for a couple of
G be that [ __ ] hero bro yeah be a
here be a life hell yes October you
don't have to be scary man buy life
insurance with policy genius go-to
policy genius calm get quotes and apply
in minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now policy genius the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance right die like a champion son
policy genius support the podcast now
there's someone had a fingernail on the
table I'm gonna try and figure out who
did eggwin to not mine not mine I got
the fingers of a pianist or somebody or
somebody looking for something real
small in a basket good at pickpocketing
huh yeah maybe good at magic huh maybe
good at magic yeah maybe you can't have
fat fingers and we get it magic you
could drink in this well sparkling water
sparkling water from what is it natural
it's cold I drink it bro cold you put
him from me I'm down in it dude up what
about put some
ice of my nuts in bro it serve you up a
refreshing badge dawg you gotta calm
down
that's bro what's up no I'm just saying
you can't drink out of it you can't who
drinks water out of a metal can dude
that's what they threw my way so I drank
it dude I feel like you're on a
different vibe because who did I feel
like you are on a different vibe because
you came back from Hawaii now I will say
this you got the sunkissed skin I'll
give you that you look good you look
good you've been surfing huh maybe
hanging out some pineapple honeys ah had
a good time man yeah mm-hmm little lilo
and stitch action uh no I don't see any
animals I'm trying to think of us all in
E or not maybe a lilo and [ __ ]
no do they don't call women [ __ ] dude
it's because they're females what
depends I mean there's some [ __ ] out
there yeah you know why you got attitude
all right
what no no no you're like a little tuna
huh do you know Jay did all of it bro
bro you dude you fall asleep with your
mouth open an official swim right into
your mouth yeah yeah that fresh cat oh
it's like that you some of that spam -
you look like the guy like spam uh olive
had spam before but not spam and what a
shame died in about 18 years spam and
shaved ice bro that's Hawaii dude it was
great I was in Maui first of all so
don't sound like let's go ye bro well
don't sound like a filthy cat hey
there's nothing worse than what Island I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah they all look the
same
yeah if you don't now E if you'll give a
Hawaii then you end up on any Island bro
that's right yeah I do it up on Staten
Island okay pina colada with the
Catalina Island thought it was about his
life right yeah short flight that's why
you don't know what it's like boy boy
Ben Nick it was good you have you been
in Maui
I've been to Maui I've been all over
Hawaii is my favorite place to go all
over Vegas term there once bro came back
with a Hawaiian shirt looking like
Hawaii five-0 all right chill out dude
chill out man I've been there a bunch no
you haven't it's my favorite place to go
here's why I dude okay hear me out here
short flight yep kind of exotic yeah
zero terrorist yeah no Isis yeah the
worst thing that's gonna happen you jump
on a wave when the locals whipped your
ass that's it
yep that's pretty good call yeah had a
good time man I went to this place PI e
it's called and just hung out man
just chilled out yeah do you surf nope
this guy was gonna teach me to surf this
guy named Ian wall she's like a famous
surfer but I didn't get to meet up with
him why not uh I already had some class
and stuff that I was going to I was
already it was like last minute did you
go in the water yeah yeah he got it bro
I'll win the water little sea turtle
dude I was in there there's all kind of
stuff in there it's beautiful
hint the best huh yeah oh yeah dude it's
great he came back refreshed I don't
know about that Brendan really all right
you know bad news
a bad mood well it's good to see them
and I was in Denver I was in Denver dog
hometown how was it good it was good a
little stressful playing playing for
your mama playing for your Papa I get
some bits are pretty racy as the kids
call it oh really yeah so it's awkward
doing friend your dad yeah talk we're
doing friend of dad doing for your mom
Derek was there oh I love your dad now
my dad loves you oh holy man his dad got
black his [ __ ] when I met him dawg it
was awesome
his dad Ruben collard greens with me out
of nowhere
that's our bill talk about hot sauce
with all the green raced a lot so I said
I said damn I have to ask you to leave
yeah he's our man y'all [ __ ] hater I
don't know why you're acting like that
and then I was like hey y'all leave all
right when the hoes at me I don't you're
married to me
please don't do that Dad Wow yeah I got
very strange did why did he ever dad it
did will he grew up around all black bye
dude he did I've never seen that side of
him he grew up slanging weed that was
his side huh yeah and caught in high
school you got kicked out of high school
graduate eventually shout out to my dad
reaches high school um
Regis high school yeah all boys I
thought it was a hospital isn't it I
think so
ha ha ha that makes a lot of sense yeah
I grew up around a lot of black dudes
than that you just brought it out of him
man his real his real spirit that's what
he said yeah he did and they did this
real cool handshake I like what they
start sagging his pants and my mom had a
way too many wobbly pops or kissing my
friend on his neck oh really she was
drinking oh yeah oh yeah a lot of
Mountain drunks up there yeah we ain't
talking about that Mountain Dew either
to me a lot of air drunks to do that
thin air up there Oh that'll get you
wobbly Oh somebody hopped up on a couple
long fools of [ __ ] inhale and next
thing you know they're breaking into
your car I took I took one hit of this
whatever Dee had you know
hi out do you forget hiring hi out that
marijuana the mary-jane uncle out there
be cool man it's like marijuana does e
you have a freaking Snoop Dogg it's
ridiculous
we share the condo I watch them like
hate Cheech and Chong can you chill out
for a second dude I took one puff kedo
not that night punch brothers pizza in
my underwear
watch me the entire punch brother pizza
my underwear was it a good pie or not I
was so high it could have been pumpkin
pie which is also good toys it's not a
good reference you're right yeah
shut up to Pudge brothers is that what
is called Pudge brother yeah oh wow and
are the guys actually bigger guys the
brothers are they you know I've never
seen them hmm we should rename this show
Pudge brothers although you're looking
you're looking at that dude [ __ ] that
wine shirt loony breath maybe button up
one of them no hi done
hey Mahalo bro you're that guy oh I'm
sorry Dog the Bounty Hunter how are you
- dude from my eyes are up here
are you back down Derek for stealing the
other day this is Island charm dude
Island charm all right give me a spam
sandwich Brock I missed you man I feel
like we haven't been in here for a while
really yeah I take smart said hey dude
excited for king the sting text back
send me a picture we wake up like this
with your shirt off like this dude be
cool but I don't wear any I knew I was
gonna write a lot of stuff and I don't
want to you know [ __ ] be strained you
know yeah did you buy a bunch of Hawaii
shirts out there let me see what did i
do man I can't really remember what did
i do I just chilled out and what else
man went in the water
I saw you picked up a hitchhiker yeah
picked up hitchhiker over there that's
he it was confusing cuz it looked a
little bit like yellow wolf no no the
guy was out to lunch I know he was still
out are you trying to die huh are you
trying to die I love hitchhikers man you
know I used to hitchhike when I was
young and it's something you can't
really do here that much anymore because
everybody's so oh no no no you know why
you can't do it huh cuz they murder
people not all of them yeah bro not all
of them dude I didn't get murdered
because you had a cuz you had a camera
on the guy so we didn't want evidence I
told her and I was like I'm just doing
this just in case you know and he's like
yeah I think cuz that's the thing when I
hitch when I when I when I hit her gets
in they don't know it's you know I'm
saying somebody's got to be the murderer
yeah could be you yeah it could be him
yeah but we know you're not murder well
so it could be him but you don't know if
you're a murderer too you pick up a
hitchhiker
you're right when you're right you're
right sometimes I want to murder a few
more drivers then what shut the [ __ ] up
well they yeah I swear I checked on the
thing no talking you did every time they
do it and they power through it they
power through it they powered through it
dude that could that could be a good
idea for a podcasters when dumb
hitchhikers you got audio setup just
find out about these people yeah this
guy was great he saving hitchhiking for
five years it's got Josiah was his name
straight out the Bible to dog it was a
biblical name dude you gotta give him a
ride you know some guy gets in he's like
oh my name's Noah you know my boat broke
down you're like alright thank God you
picked up didn't look like you did drugs
at all they do they have a meth problem
they call it ice no it's not nighttime
about shaved ice oh yeah bro Oh meth and
Hawaii's big is it Oh big how are you
gonna do math and be out like at the
beach that sounds crazy you're there all
day yeah you're wiling out they did have
some people who were living on the beach
you know dude you should have picked
them up and the pretend it was Cash Cab
and start asking random questions and
not
yeah Navid oh I'm just [ __ ] with you
man
I have a good day dude what about crash
cab you pick them up and then crash in
the Sun and see or you are slashed have
you pick them up and just listened to
Guns and Roses the whole name that tune
yeah
you can win money let me don't man I
don't think it'd be that great actually
like it's a good idea I feel like you
would kill that show like Cash Cab but
you're just picking up random strangers
cuz you don't shut the [ __ ] up anyways
so you just like keep talking though
because you got you got a lot of
knowledge to drop man sighs I'm sayin
you could pitch up like yeah what do you
say anyone who's hitchhiking probably
not doing very well you know if there's
uber but basically yeah but there's like
document is like just where you know
there's proof of where you been at I
guess we had new culture corner today
yeah tell Lacey the pele she's in the
house look at oh man look at oh yeah one
of my favorite people nicest guy in the
world really the nice skin I am really
nice to go to anger management for how
long years high school in college I know
when did you realize you had a problem
bro I didn't realize they told me that
was please don't tell van said
yeah why'd it take years cuz it doesn't
stop there doesn't [ __ ] stop you
little [ __ ] you need anger management
it's fun Ali boy yeah yeah it's fun
mm-hmm but here's the other thing about
Chappelle your president know this do
nor do you care
he was a cheerleader I know that male
chouhi nothing him do a roundoff back
handspring dude
I've done more than a roundoff back
handspring thank you very much male
cheerleader with an attitude problem be
cool bro sorry being aggressive yes dude
you got to work on your dues got daggers
and his pom-poms that Chinese stars in
it such a great superhero oh that would
be cool they're also called Power
Rangers true Power Rangers are all
cheerleaders I'll be the Pink Ranger Dan
oh it's just a color sure man everybody
I know that was aggressive to you know
get the mic out of my face all right
yeah we need to talk to your supervisor
Wow
culture core is getting big brother yeah
it is thick over there huh thick with
three C's and a good way though yeah
good I'm only talk to Derek and
Chappelle cat please don't sue me oh
really dude he went to Portland with me
he went to Portland with me with his
dynamite dude you should try Cougars
yeah I'm down for that meal comes he
it's a giant burrito to muffins like oh
damn dog it was something crazy
he said I'll start when I get back yeah
that's what I'm saying reincarnation
dude eat what you want in this life
start when you get back
that's what I'm talking about they
Chappelle headlining his first weekend
did you we're going to this week
yeah House of comedy Minnesota oh why
October 3rd through 6th
Saturday and Sunday this is my first
headlining weekend is yeah
congratulations
yeah I'm excited proud of you man guys
we're Knights huh yeah in the mall huh
in that mall dude the malls crazy they
have four American Eagles in there and
true yeah and they have real someone's
found a real American Eagle in there one
time peacocks yeah I wrote a hippo how
big is it it's because it's the biggest
mall in America but the biggest is in
Edmonton which same place though it's
exact same mall same owners yeah Wow a
shooting range
yeah use that parking gun you can go no
[ __ ] yeah they do they got rides
pirates it's crazy
no Paisley Park yeah we're cool and be
cool is this good you've been talking a
lot of crap about how about how you lied
said you ran a 4-3 in the 40 I've been
around the game too long Chappelle I
love you
okay downhill for Tea Party yeah on a
skateboard in a rocket all right listen
now okay you still skateboard yeah I
still get down uh-huh yeah mm-hmm bigger
board though oh I'm just saying you
can't have a small board all in and [ __ ]
like 250 pounds more like I uh y-you say
like a long board why you videos if you
know my weight yeah are you not
I mean you write like that he guessed it
right though like Pro gains recognize
game pounds recognize pounds big bicular
some [ __ ] cultural dog roll everybody
thinking here like you and chin and
Catman that's true I'm working on it I
swear
are you trying to lean out yeah man why
you back to that cheer body really Oh
y'all hey y'all hey
all right you know what you okay let's
say cheer body though I want to talk to
you ain't making it to your car you
ain't making it to you hey man
note to self don't record away to
culture I was all fun again see start
threatening his brother on dude cheer
body we need some namaste yeah sorry I'm
super dark arts you feel me getting dark
test what y'all say about dark I didn't
say nothing Chappelle's dark I'm not the
nice skin either
now spells dark oh yeah I'm just dark
here so meet him bro you set your clock
forward an hour I've heard so many dark
jokes and that's probably the best one
ever
look you two stay down 32 years old and
I've been hearing dark jokes all my life
and I have never that's a good one see
him in Minneapolis this weekend very
funny do you know my mom said yes came
the show and people are talking or you
know she was making sure everyone knew
she was my mom really started heck gonna
have to put in a place a little bit to
start the show but then after I had to
yeah I know it's awful
it was ratchet it was a half a bathing
suit yeah dude come on keep going she
ready
is happening mom then they gave me the
standing ovation while mom was clapping
cheeks in the bag like in Jesus right
now dude how do you think I feel that's
my family but my mom sone goes oh you
want the office Leigh find the kid you
watch kidding sting she goes I can't
they're too mean to each other
really wait mom come on we're not mean
to each other
Britten's mean sometimes you're super
mean them really oh yeah you're way
meaner let's go to corner who's mean
chin Chin's are gonna say Derek who's
been feels feels me feels me but it's
funny and then you're mean and it's like
me just mean it's way more mean but it's
funny yeah anyone you're mean it's way
less mean but it's like interesting Mean
Gene they call you interesting cat you
take the same position I'm in cat Oh
interesting
I think view has that like backhanded
like southern insult thing just like
inherently in him like Oh bless your
heart yeah it's where I'm from we call
that an [ __ ] meaner but because the
humor kind of softens the punch we let
it we literally yeah you're not as mean
but it's like you're both [ __ ]
though let's start this episode you're
good to be back how soon will Katsu's us
is what I want to that's what I think
about it every night let's ask her every
night before I go to go faster do you
guys want a two-week notice before I do
so now I just hit me with it man yeah
he'll put it in hit me I have your best
shot time to buy few more pants if you
get a king and stained shirt whatever
yet maybe send your momma T frickin CSAT
album
yeah maybe scent of TP I don't know what
your mom's into but you shipstation calm
the fastest easiest most affordable way
to manage and ship your orders bro yeah
you got a wig
for your wig mom send her that on
shipstation since your dad a slinky bro
dude
send your damn one of those electric
Cooter's you know that you could plug in
at a wall
oh here's the thing last night no matter
what you're selling if you're selling it
through Amazon Etsy your own website
whatever you selling cracklins you
selling hair barrettes you know what I'm
saying you selling a new tire tread or
change or Teochew yeah what worms yeah
see monkeys yeah shipstation brings all
your orders into one simple interface
dude no wonder ship stations the number
one choice of online sellers you'll ship
more and less time with the best rates
period CB d e BD d BD DVD they got it
all you could ship anything no wonder
ship station is the number one choice
online seller said that bro and right
now I'm saying something new okay King
and the sting listeners can try ship
station for free for 60 days 60 days use
the code Kat yeah
there's no risk you can start your free
trial without even entering your credit
card info yep visit ship station calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in ka TS ship
station enter offer code cat's ship
station comm make ship happen
someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit oh man I use this yesterday
tune me to know you talking about that
post mates at post mais doesn't use post
mate
I don't know lepers probably people with
lepers leper
either way post mates is fantastic maybe
you want red wine at 4:00 p.m. sushi you
want a burrito maybe you want cookies
yeah maybe you want to listen to some
Timberlake and just cry yourself a river
you know ya might as well have a snack
while you do it maybe you wanna listen
to Michael Jackson be bad he a bunch of
cupcakes yeah I do might as well have a
snack while you do it you sad little
bass maybe listen a Big Pun and the
Punisher yeah I need a whole cheese
pizza like I did the other day and then
tell everyone you're on keto listen Post
Bates is the best personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever kind of
delivery service you want
year-round 24/7 365 days a year
and it's not just for you send a bagel
do a couple brothers you know or
something you know what I'm saying
order up a salad for your ex-girlfriends
then a six-pack to your little crush
online yeah dude here's some orange
crush from my crush
here's a bunch of Capri Suns for that
ass post mates is Jim you guys $100 off
and free delivery credit for your first
seven days think about it think about it
start your free deliveries download the
app and use the code Kay 80s 2019 think
about it
that's cats 2 0 1 9 for $100 a free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when download the post mates app think
about it now do it anything you need
anytime you need it postmates ok knock
knock who's there
pantheon Brendan what do we got our
little debate club sure man yeah how
these things working
Wow first we got Ethan Calhoun oh yeah
little bumble Rumble what well in audio
guy this is my favorite guy this is this
deal in Hawaii in four oh we're doing it
from freaking dude you got to go to Maui
dude no you have not vote I asked nobody
see you dude huh no I'm gonna do it soon
yeah we should do a tour of there should
you did so host that's worse your first
game thing yeah yeah why yeah those
Islands I think they want stand up
though they don't want a couple of goofs
[ __ ] screwin around
yeah you might be right man you guys are
both goofs yeah we've been Hawaii dirt
what's with the fam oh wow really
they're 9/11 whoa oh wow wow yeah so
that others burgers knows em bro
I don't want Derek failing my foxhole
[Laughter]
and I gotta miss like two months of
school because we couldn't fly back
during that you know during that so it
was a good time for you really only for
you is good when the [ __ ] hits the fan
two posts it's gonna Hawaii giving
shoutouts Osama
Wow Wow
and what you guys do during 9/11 and
stuff cat I gathered around a TV while I
was at school and we all watched it how
old were you cry I was I think like a
first in first grade Wow
young to be taught in TV for the kids
man Oh too young turn on the TV for kids
seeing planes wrecking the buildings
that's true isn't it yeah Chappelle what
were you doing I was late for school
so you missed all of it yeah I woke up
and I said where's New York allsports he
nearly went to public school what state
were you in Arizona man oh wow yeah
heart Mesa oh wow yeah yeah yeah the
straight-up illegal I know I shouldn't
be here right now I got this in Bob way
blood yeah whoa country over there dude
that dudes a gangster around doesn't
intense is he the one that puts the
inmates in the pink suits pink suits and
used to have a thing called tent city
yeah you put them in
well they got rid of they'd make him
kiss out the sheriff and you know come
camp in the desert oh yeah and it was
like he was like Bobby Knight basically
yes he was crazy yeah he was wild he's
been assured us for as long as I could
he's still alive he's still alive but
he's not the sheriff anymore yeah I
think he got to I guess he got too old
he got oh no he not even get they just
he didn't win right time he wouldn't do
that for the rest of a lot rest of his
life if it could Wow
he's like the warden from Shawshank huh
from Shawshank yeah he's a saint
yeah sorry aggressive-aggressive got a
remembrance sorry forget what a mess
you know yeah you know put me in a
cheerleading gym I'm happy I'm saying
this in competition come back in let's
kick this off we got the volume is this
Andy Dick what's going on this is about
Randy Dick's career is right now say
that boy even count the two of you guys
are the greatest duo since Martin and
Lewis you're far superior to Milli
Vanilli or shields and Yarnell you might
need to look them up today's debate club
question is quite simple thoughts or pop
rocks I know you don't need to look them
up oh yeah one more thing the culture
quarter rocks double gang the square
this guy hey little mascot
first of all Kathy Griffin fell off but
not surprising at first of all I'm not
I'm not mad at cheer tops new gimmick
that's it as fire
he's one candy out of the trunk now yeah
whoo shout out that I got Martin and
Lewis from who is that where's he from
he's from the east Rita guys or is it
Martin Lewis yeah I think those the old
comedy Oh super old school comedy doing
the original comedy duo who founded
America are founded yes
Oh Lewis and Clark boy Zots were this
I'm not too familiar with Zod's they're
like the soured what they did like the
fizzy middle no one knows huh yeah
that's our little random now up so pop
rocks all goddamn day I put on my mouth
you like him I loved him rocks huh yeah
but it's out of a dangerous candy for me
I remembered I remember had I had a
couple I think I 2 of how many are in
the package there's a bunch in this one
pack you can dump a ball in your mouth
and just listen to crackle pop oh yeah
if you want to have CTE later in life I
wanted to live a regular existence so I
remember having one or two of us of the
raw that's fair and then choosing not to
have any
when I remember having a lot of liquor
made look it made oh I know those eyes
remind me of warheads that's why I was
trying to think of about seven episodes
ago CT my ass warheads weird oh yeah
you're wondering for seven or maybe that
sciency yeah we did just hit me bro yeah
warheads worth a [ __ ] oh you guys long
time about Chappell no candy ever huh
really why would happen to me miss it
don't fit my aggression damn really what
is it like what do you mean about it
like candy it's just too sweet yeah you
know you don't have any sweet teeth no
even those front two you got there hey
what's up man why you got to do that
you'd have to point that out great team
that's why the line [ __ ] you you can
sound like the bad guy you have a great
team anything about my skin tone but
when you talk about this guy Michael
Strahan do with the same guy that's the
oldest one in the book worst joke I've
ever heard about my bro
I don't have sweet I don't have a sweet
tooth i sweet teeth like all all sugar
do you you're not a sugar guy I'll have
some I don't mind like a uh maybe a
creme brulee or something that night but
you know or some a bread pudding you
know but nothing like a twizzler or a
Red Vine or some runts oh you should
have runts when I was young I remember
from think 6th and 7th grade I want to
enjoy a good boxer run yeah I feel like
once would be your thing as a kid with a
backpack full of runt
we used to play this game sugar we put
as much sugar you couldn't mount them
try to slap it out of each other's
mouths
Oh ziti sugar box because the moisture
would all absorb as much as it could and
so then you were real dried out and
trying to beat that sugar out of each
other damn call struggle sugar beat no
sugar boys was a game tell you was a
game of stuff no I'm saying we could do
it now ok no you get your
kool-aid in your mouth the raw kool-aid
the powder coin oh yeah that's living
brother your tongue will be that color
for the rest of the month
and what you guys play back in the home
country okay from American San Jose in
my neighborhood you used to just try to
stay out of the way of colas and ABG
away from would you eat candy or I mean
shitty childhood if you had if you had
candy they wanted to steal it from you
so you had to run off you win you keep
your candy if not get your ass beat you
look like you're kind of fast had enough
so so it was a lot of so there's a lot
of gang violence and stuff in the area
yes very ethnic gang violence wow this
is what you wanted I thought I wanted
this Derek can you know write your ideas
out before you you're right you're right
I just set everything up and then here
we are I think is chosen you cancelled
we're gonna get attacked by ms9 or
whatever
cats old neighbors are mourning for us
it was all fun and games just messing
around bro so debate pop rocks but
really warheads for me well the man
asked pop rocks resorts dude this is a
gentleman who spent time to put that
together and send that in this Zots man
who is that what you man same Lonnie
Ethan couch Oh Ethan Calhoun brother
first of all
and he might be black I didn't see the
mask how much so the I can't tell what
the mask what is that a Riddler's mask
he's wearing Oh his face looks kind of
white a little bit I'm not mad at the B
though yeah that buzz logo oh yeah you
be the president the fan club he wants
that's your that's your hitch beneath
the Ethan Calhoun fan club right there
SID
does he say what city he lives in not a
lot of details huh underground is it be
yeah you right um pop rocks though right
oh yeah 93 percent we're with pop rocks
are you should done warhead to pop rocks
well yeah hit it on the candy from
present day you know he should have done
a post 1985 sweet you eat lion brother
what do you got all right up next we got
Daniel Vernon what up Theo what up
Brennan huge fan in the podcast
appreciate what you guys do you guys
appreciate it we'll do any matter of
fact I think both games are Java Theo he
looks like a high school lacrosse coach
who [ __ ] all the players Oh
your equipment kiddo I got a debate club
for you guys I really recently went to
storage and dug out my old gaming
systems and I want to know when you guys
were kids were you on that Super
Nintendo were you on that Sega Genesis
are you getting those coins with Mario
were you that Sonic the Hedgehog getting
those rings yeah now you also might
recognize this little guy that's the Rat
King baby
gang bro yeah let me know what you guys
think Gang Gang buzzbuzz culture culture
cultural culture you guys get a little
all right in a little respect out there
might be the last week you're here but
we're gonna get shanked like violent you
leaders dude I thought it was cool man
oh he's the male Lindsay Lohan over
there
is broke that Stacy - over there she
just hit somebody did she really
she's a bad [ __ ] really I think I
interviewed her one time oh she is bad
remember in clueless she never did
anything after that but still she was
that clueless die me dime she was yeah
Stacy - yeah I remember clueless I think
what else did he ask what this man asked
oh what's this guy one for Nintendo or
Sega Genesis Oh Super Nintendo
I think Sega Genesis some weird kid
always had the Sega Genesis to me it was
like what is it it's kind of shaped
weird like yeah which is good and put
the cartridge is on top yeah that was
all Montana football for games those
rules are no Sega Genesis don't remember
they had odd world if you remember that
was Abe the alien that walked around the
outside a crash bandicoot remember that
but that was later though the crash came
out was later the crash and he's your
friend though okay that's later that
Crash Bandicoot game so they originally
hit with the Sonic the Hedgehog yes then
they came with tails right NBA Jam no
NBA Jam Sega Genesis I thought our Super
Nintendo what was it on merit yeah I
don't think you could play NBA I thought
maybe NBA Jam stars on arcade and then
went to thing really yeah well then that
band that's the winner NBA Jam he's on
fire
there that yeah look it up bring that
[ __ ] up D remember how great that was an
americorps Malone and Stockton Gary
Payton and Shawn Kemp oh he get home you
get actually touch me
[Laughter]
what are you know candy no I was on both
systems I don't know came out hot with
both and then remember the Spurs you
could have Tim Duncan and David Robinson
yeah yeah it was pretty Jordan was never
in it though huh
Shakalaka yeah
from downtown I think you could be you
could get a cheat code me being good
ball for sure he's on fire but back into
that double dribble remember that game
yeah you could sure white guy was on the
Colonel's and feet away and facing the
other shot like this yeah and then you
could face that way dude I like contra
that's that's Super Nintendo - yeah
contra was good contra was regular
Nintendo as well
left right left right up down up down a
B a B select start Wow and you do that
you've been practicing on CT my ass baby
it's a lot huh there's my game bro that
was my game was it yeah contra NBA Jam
what else a tecmo bowl do you play
techno yeah come on bro
yeah jeopardy family feud and with you
that's a good game and if you want to go
PC join your PC we got Wolfenstein doom
when you're seven Plumas or anything you
[ __ ] your pants
that thing was scary dude and then
Wolfenstein Nazi killing was it oh yeah
Wolfenstein bro I didn't kill Nazis I
didn't see it was so intense I was seven
dad yeah no wonder your moms [ __ ]
wearing a bathing suit at a comedy show
trapping bro yeah dude here's what I'm
saying is super nes dude Sega Genesis
was for somebody that was strange I felt
like or were just different maybe yeah
yeah yeah cuz some kiss on sonic was a
bit of a beast of a game now
was a great game what you never knew
anybody that had it it was always to me
it was so foreign brother always had it
many I don't know where he got him he
said the new [ __ ]
hey type in top Sega games because we're
missing one cuz they I know Sega maybe
that was Sega what was Street Fighter
was Super Nintendo Streets of Rage beast
altered beast I remember that game
Golden Axe yeah they had some o toejam
and Earl bro that's you and me no it is
bring up toe jam Earl I'm the big one
you're the skinny one toe jam and her
never played toe jam and earl that's you
and me bro that's you and me I do
remember that that was a game no was it
that whatever TV show wasn't it I don't
know but it's a crazy game riddance
yeah maybe dude you and me are toejam
and earl toejam and earl did i remember
that i go back to the other list this is
a throwback memory lane here mmm
Disney's Aladdin get in my face Sonic
that's I'm saying the games got real
weak y'all had uh Oh what is that one
right there you came out hot oh [ __ ] oh
yeah be the revenge of shinobi and there
you go yeah I got a little keep going to
say Tetris on that get on my face man
yeah see this [ __ ] gets weird
Oh your homework that's a game I said
this [ __ ] is horrible earthworm jim was
my favorite did I think he got molested
that's what that sounds like
you don't know earthworm jim huh and
gave your body nicknames
you might be right yes because I didn't
have a second we would do it all the
time
[Laughter]
earthworm jim was big what do we got so
I'm gonna go with Super Nintendo just
cuz of NBA Jam
you know what I'll go is take a dude is
because I hate it and I'm trying to be
different
56% went with Sega boom you a little
[ __ ] oh sorry
got that text from you happy can you
have your guy texting about anger and my
bad dude I should have said that man you
know I'm a fan of both dude you know you
did get you do call it right
all right boys little punk man hater
called you a [ __ ] I'm okay about the
Sega gasps no I'm me too
okay but the reason called me a [ __ ] is
cuz I said Super Nintendo you went Sega
oh yeah that's but I like both record
Jessica said oh you do I got it right
you know yeah Evan the nice thing to do
yeah sorry what else all right boys up
first we got uncle Jeff this is uncle
Jeff yo Danny I'm gonna Jeff's I bro
Jeff is a talented musician you don't
have to see his eye first okay remember
when you had an eye patch yeah that [ __ ]
was cool man
oh yeah oh that [ __ ] was cool yeah well
we know now you're supportive of it I
guess she'll be me what happened I pass
on we're supposed to pretend he doesn't
to me you could be jewel that thing up
make it real swaggy on the street so
when you see something that I paid for
the first four minutes dude it's not a
kit bro yeah ignore it you pretend they
don't have it okay after that you can
talk about it okay let's check out this
all right go ahead he's Jewish he's a
Deadhead he has aphasia I bet he's a you
gotta say that Grateful Dead
yeah you can't say a dead head around I
got it you know that I doubt it's a
dying head
sorry uncle Jeff he has a hope I'm
saying this right of aphasia or effusion
and it's the loss or ability to
understand speech caused by a brain
damage shoutout to our boy Jack is this
guy just the future me the only words he
never forgets how to say our [ __ ] and
[ __ ] jack
that's what I'm talking about dude
that's all that's Derek also it sounds
like a little bit guys awesome that's it
huh yeah that's all we know about uncle
Jeff uncle Jeff man hey they don't throw
in what happened to his eye huh no I
think it might have to do with the
aphasia but I'm not a hundred percent
and if faiza also is a girl from my
hometown I believe as well also most
strippers if you have ever been aphasia
and also a Disney movie with Mickey
Mouse that in he plays instruments mm
fascia
that's plantation no that's about racism
no no you think of 12 years of so you're
thinking of 12 years of Fantasia yeah
yeah plantation insane dude oh my gosh I
do miss musics good but I don't support
that kind of [ __ ] do I own the
soundtrack yeah but I'm not gonna watch
it again what else we got oh it sounds
like Kanye West's new CD drop its
Kanye's new album bro Chappelle with a
leading lady
[Laughter]
I want to be where the people are I
wanna show - let's [ __ ] turn up do
you think this mr. Brown for it bro the
words Broadway oh we wouldn't look at
Hakuna Matata bro
Ching can sing too - she would be lead
vocal we're super culture yeah dude
let's throw around the c-word right yeah
man up next we got another uncle Jeff -
Jeff's yep this is from Salt Lake this
uncle Jeff well goddamn Jeff looks like
I've met this guy before I mean he may
have the same barber apparently that can
be look that can feed me look at the
second pitch is he the second one oh wow
yeah he looks very similar this guy is
swagtastic look at his outfit it's kind
of this guy's this guy's dope I wish she
was my Uncle Dan that guy's a
straight-up swag dragging on with that
baby that matches that shirt I know this
is what is this rip it's so fun yeah
this is freaking trip daddy baby that
this uncle's not messing around
yeah sure that is you is it yeah he's
not yeah I don't like your sinister
smile holding that kid don't say that
right now
that ain't a sinister smile that's a
swag smile right no he's swagged out on
the right look at him I'm taking a kid
yeah this is like trying to meet a lady
you take the little law the Bichon to
the park or whatever we shine that baby
maybe shop
I'll tell you that much right now I know
a bichon yeah be shunned yeah that ain't
him that ain't him Tanner Tanner that's
Chapman I bet this dude could dance I'll
tell you that much
oh yeah here's one white guy in the band
that does the dance with the stick you
know what I'm talking yeah you know he
went to a black college yeah no he went
to a black cop he was a Grambling State
ten white Howard College University was
a hair salon probably no how are you
don't learn that in the white
neighborhood uncle we've had on you know
just a fire what else we got that's it
for pokémon boys say give me another
Jeff something's up yeah a little
relationship advice guys we always help
them all right we always helpful ruining
our lives
yeah you're right this is mad I'm gonna
keep trying though you know yeah you're
right though man that's true my attitude
needs to change I'm gonna keep trying as
well let's if we can help this guy Matt
Farrell ask for help over the one guy
that had his wife trapped in the back of
the car and then asked us to delete the
video did you submitted it I think it's
gonna blast me out like that no my wife
family knows like you submit the video
we didn't ask for it yet its wife
sitting in a child seat in the back dude
she's like this yes she was like shut up
to that guy hopefully she's still alive
yeah Jane gang buzz buzz jealous
my name's Matt I'm from Waterford
Michigan
me and my girlfriend been together for
two years
first you know it was great my
girlfriend man she is just she's just so
rude and mean sometimes yeah oh yeah you
know love her to death
yeah is me she's a lot of sex it's good
she's like but man just that attitude
yeah sometimes man it's too much to
handle yep I'm not type of guy man to
degrade women or talk back to women I'm
sometimes yeah shaken like that so you
know I try not to engage back there man
but you know she's just rude really rude
and mean you know just hangin and so
well is to be broken and I want to be
with her but it just doesn't seem like
anything's gonna change the way that she
she reacts to me and treats me you know
so you know of ice getting gang Buzzz
Buzzz brothers appreciate a man I need
more details if I'ma solve this case
brother this first 48 I mean detective T
or on it this an episode of Hawaii
five-o this it might be but I know what
an ethnicity [ __ ]
bruh you know I'm sayin this is the
easiest thing to solve he need to stop
being a [ __ ] now aggressive I'm sorry
what's his name Brad you need to go back
there anymore right that's what they
told me an anger management stop being a
[ __ ] and look at me that's true yeah
yeah well was that what was you to do
they say you get angry because you're
what is that one of the reasons why I
grew up very violent but when they say
though Thank You management they say
stop being is that one of the things
they tell you no they don't say it
directly but is one of the reasons you
were angry maybe because you were small
and like bigger kids were picking on you
so like a bigger kid I was picking on me
was my stepfather yeah that's the big
kid right I can handle the kids at
school yes when I got home that was like
damn this is a hard fight to fight huh
yeah an eight-year-old unique and funny
that's all we got Hey well he can't come
at me now
I love him when you told me a lot yeah I
love got that head work it's a horrible
dude but I love that guy I mean yeah he
just needs some confidence in himself
yeah there's confidence boss oh dude
I'll put up with some yeah if she's fine
enough I'll put him with some yeah bad
movies she might throw a little racist
term here and there like yeah I guess
but I put up with it dude if she's that
fine man if that happens I'll leave the
room man but you come back huh
yeah come back with snacks yeah flaming
hot cheetos I gotta find out this girl's
Latin she's my girl meet that sometime
like Jam let's go to a young lady that
we have here we have a young lady on
premises and let's chat with her because
we need some help because why I don't
know well my girl is not the friendliest
yeah they're latin dude yeah but I feel
like cats mean to her man look everybody
likes to date a girl with the attitude
problem until they have to date a girl
with that attitude you're welcome people
always think is so fun to date a
passionately go on a pit bull speaker
mic exactly and you don't want a pit
bull when it comes to dealing with a
play supporting Hillary Connor yes you
win the shirt till it's time to vote and
y'all put that [ __ ] stick around like
an [ __ ] exactly want that pimple -
it's time to do some pit bull [ __ ] so
you throw that frisbee and he attacks a
family
people's are crazy like felons the like
felony they kill a family of four it's
like they come back wagging tails come
back with a mouthful of barrettes you
like got violent
I'm sorry cat and I think I stepped over
when you were when you're talking to
we would suggest when you give us
because yeah if maybe the man feels
emasculated it sounds like a little bit
but I feel like a lot of girls do that
over time they don't respect them no
overtime overtime it's easy not to
respect your significant other no you're
that dick game that yeah it is isn't it
yeah I don't know what it is well you
take people you take people for granted
and then get brittle and big you really
mean to him you take him for granted you
know you do man I ain't gonna be either
every day yeah you phoned me poured down
yeah you forget why you were with them
or what's going on but What did he say
he said that the girls mean and then he
first he said she's rude then he said
she's mean I'd have to know well if
she's ethnic though if they listen
listen bro when they're ethnic and they
got that attitude but they got them
well Aileen Wuornos dogs she was curvy
dude yeah can't handle the curves well
if you can't handle the [ __ ] lizards
to get out the lot you feel ha ha ha
Eileen Warren it's the number one lot
lizard of all time wasn't she remember
her the movie monster yes she was the
number one lot lizard and she took she
took charge of her life yeah she was a
the only female serial killer son wait
I've never seen a the Tina Turner movie
with Ike and Tina brah
she's she mean to him no she beat him
the [ __ ] up well Whitney Houston Bobby
Brown I heard his good fights I did too
Tommy Davidson told me they were good
fight I heard that
Rihanna Chris Brown I'll buy that [ __ ]
again I will watch it
so you got that reach of the legs didn't
hurt she bit him yeah yeah she bit him
that's why freaked out dude I'll tell
you to some friends with a ShamWow guy
Vince right with who Vince from Samwell
Moran I'd keep selling that in my face
yeah all right well he got accused a he
got accused of hitting a woman one time
in Miami it make sense but the woman had
bit on to him like one of those fish on
the side of the Suckerfish yeah and he
had no way to get her off so what'd he
do evie try to get him more food and
stuff
he cut a ShamWow her off and uh usually
he's the aggressive force hitting and
then so what happened does she take your
choice call the police
yes chicken out of his face oh yeah so
there was a bite that happened to that
soap opera dude who's a dime piece he
had a wife had a side piece on the side
something happened with the side piece
she bit his lip off yeah that's what you
get somebody did it to Lester whole bit
is [ __ ] lip off Daly look at Lester
hole dude here's the number one Dateline
episode where's your top lip at last all
right let's get a picture of Lester
holed up here dude really yeah this dude
looking for all these mysteries and
somebody right yeah Oh Derek definitely
one of the worst between Derek and chin
as far as the googling skill never any
good yeah bro he can't even hold a
mustache oh hold on a second from I
don't [ __ ] know if Lester oldest
black dude look at [ __ ] Lester old
you tell me that's not a white dude in
blackface look at him look at the
monitor I think he goes I think your
chocolate body 24/7 ain't a [ __ ]
black dude look at him that's black he
black no he's no we ain't look at that
picture what the [ __ ] is Sudan hey go to
his Wikipedia it says his Seva says his
parents
he's not black they got along his hairs
on the side he's mixed mixed with a lot
of white yes okay all right you write
about that one now look at this has a
bit much
that's a little aggressive I thought I
was aggressive but the same this will
redeem him that last that's a black man
there on his rise that he might be like
a Michael Jackson I don't know if that I
mean really pointing Sammy Sosa at it
yeah just how you gonna send me so what
no James just gets the lotion so he's
white yeah that's a real thing the
whitening lotion yeah you've seen Sammy
Sosa lately it's fantastic
he might be a white man I never thought
it on my level I've seen over probably
six hundred episodes of Dateline and you
don't I've never thought that until just
now is like that just doesn't look like
a black man to me yeah that's the
whitest [ __ ] you can do that's pretty
why I'm with you on this case bro damn
Lester Holt is white down case all I was
room for y'all shot y'all trying to take
him but I was I ain't notice people try
to claim them he's with me in there okay
even a car culture no Lester wait you
might give me the Crayola corner bright
you got some paint on it what someone
Sammy Sosa salmon so so they called him
Eastern price [ __ ] is heaven the city
swam upstream as far away from the black
river could give bro he is but he ain't
black who's him he says well he was
Porto Rican black yeah well dominican
black teen oh yeah I get mistaken for a
Dominican all the time do you really I
could see that now darker Dominican no
yeah baseball hat on no four times like
the Batman of the
Republic he has the best dark job he's
like yeah nice races dude on the race
one yeah he was making fun of my gap I
made a reference how cool your gap is
all of a sudden I'm the bad guy
meanwhile he's friends with Shamu beats
women and the head of the KKK Duke he's
the spot I'm on the squat rack but on
the races okay on benchpress you [ __ ]
okay he's a nice guy but just swap
[ __ ] supplements Duke and I'm racist
because my dad got a little flavor and
my mom twerks all right I see how it is
what else we got Dee get us out of here
give me out of here we got a couple we
got a couple ripped my dreams boys up
first this is Dave from New Jersey
oh [ __ ] Dave literally a fan of women's
lingerie football WWF or WTF dawg that's
what would women oh that's that one from
New Jersey and they got bored and just
throwing his girl's Halloween costume
and you guys always playing I like this
dude respect
that's for y'all oh that's dope oh damn
bro nice tits yeah one nice I came that
other ones are far from a sense yeah one
of them stick the other one I can't tell
ya got that big gap between the tits
whoa Jesus man yeah oh dude I can't say
gap man I like this guy now is that uh
Adamic sue for the because he's balling
this season some people get it corner
gets and amicus she I love it dude
that's what I'm saying put on your wife
[ __ ] and go out there and do some bad
[ __ ] you know I'm saying I'll show her
who's boss yeah break a total car
windows or something you know
you do get on tinder with that outfit
see what's up sure what's up yeah rear
naked choke a [ __ ] cocker spaniel
brain change the neighborhood up slap a
hound dog around yeah that's a ever I
live your life boy I like this dude
that's what I'm saying dude what else we
got what's this guy's name Walter Dave
Dave
hell yeah Jay now hold on here's
something you got to think about this is
girls Halloween costume and she fits
into that she said she yeah no I don't
think so he didn't ruin the outfit gonna
put on Ripper [ __ ] she yeah she sounds
like a beautiful lady and she sounds
like sounds like they both played attack
for Oklahoma look Hilda's got excited
like okay sidelines on that hashmark
skateboard yeah
boy is this a wig that he has on or not
that's the tough part I would assume
that's a wig but I'm not sure actually
that's cool I don't know he's doped on
my fan he's a bad [ __ ] player what else
we got we got a up next we got Robert
Battaglia this is Robert Vitya Brennan
this is right before your show in
Houston big dog Shh
never been so close to canceling a
weekend ever in my life he said he's
super glad you didn't cancel he'd have
been [ __ ] pissed he had a great time
and I know it yeah I figured if I can
sigh we lost the entire crowd look what
he stood it for you true however CNN
chill the [ __ ] out
I got there bone-dry really there's
nothing there
Houston knows that a lot they're like
always flooding here and you get there
and everybody doing fine yeah there's
fine
I drove down from Austin that morning I
was all worried I'll have to cancel get
there nothing really
no nothing my guess was on the outskirts
but CNN was like Houston's under water
or showed like a Kea floating by upside
damn I don't like to do this but I did
it that's for your tactics they got yes
well what is proud boys uh so I'm gonna
take this one I got in trouble last done
per I think there are like a group of
white dudes no no I'm saying go ahead
I'm not sorry but I think they're grupo
I do is who hate everybody but like I
don't know this is in FIFA and there's
our boys and they don't like each other
are they don't like each other so
they're riding out there this huge riot
so everyone's like don't come to
Portland that week it's gonna be trouble
chin came I was worried for his safety
I'm worried
will you worry Ken or not do you have
feelings of worry ever it was anyway it
was a little weird down there shows were
great yeah I brought the whole culture
corner with me during the proud boy
rally yeah and then I look Mexican but I
took a picture from the whole freaking
SWAT team and the proud boys like this
did you yeah who's your team probably is
Maureen if I have to pick if I had to
pick if it's a game yeah if it's a game
then proud boys were Milan bro but and
Tifa has more players and probably more
quality players who's gonna punch it in
from the one now at an Tifa really yeah
yeah and they didn't seem to be affected
by the tear gas
yeah actually encouraged what's this
question though I just wanted you to
repair it oh hell yeah that raindrip
done that raindrip looks like al
Madrigal a little bit little guys also
like the cake run up from it that gets
murdered in the first minute of the
movie okay yeah the fake nosing glass is
hot it doesn't make a sound putting like
about a forty pounds looks like it's on
if he actually ate meals yeah what is
this sound still fasting for I'm
confused on their culture I really don't
know but it's fasting 24/7 bonito
yeah just says praise Allah and then
just keeps fasting yeah fast man
sometimes he'll turn on the oven and
just get in
for like a half-hour and just kind of
it'll come back just to smell what it's
like yeah it's very strange
all right boys any with a little king
under sting it up it's the king and us
thing I want sergeants thing anymore huh
we got Austin Barrett this is Austin
praise God brother sting it for you
cliff jumping genes boo in Jesus damn
that's gangster Wow great video
shout-out to Nebraska where is he in
Kuala Lumpur where was yeah he's in
Nebraska Oh Nebraska no why is that
correctly uh cliff jumping for music me
a hard pass
I did in college at Table Rock in
Missouri and it's a place where everyone
jumped off as the middle of the summer
right and so all my friends are there so
you take a boat there and I was like ah
it's not that high like really you do
them like y'all do it we hike up there
it's high it once you get up there yes
so high I didn't want to do it all my
friends jumped in like damn I do not
want to do this and then some drunk dude
I'm like getting ready to go and there's
ice trying to impress these girls and
the guys on the boat with the girls goes
jump off sir I thought I I thought it
was you dude I jumped your boy belly
flop hit my face contact when everywhere
water my ear awful experience never do
get your eye open when you [ __ ] lame
you know it's forced the boom contact
boom you got stronger I oh yeah you
right it's not for me I brushed it need
to be stronger but listen for your
eyelids you got to be especially valid I
think so let me see clear no no no don't
do that don't squint just close them
there you go yeah and close your mouth
too and you do with this nicely bro
hey hey Craig's father just close your
eyes I vomit in your day
unbelievable like close your eyes he's
like you've changed a lot
oh do you know I did before I went home
I'm not afraid to MIT this that to use a
little bit of just for men I thought
about you you ever use just for men just
for man for what my tinder profile I can
hair off
no it's for uh dyeing your hair just a
little brush exciting all these Gracie
I'm like damn I was like these gray hair
stress so I just put a little little
color there dog can't even tell right my
mom wakes I'm girl my hair out yeah
let's go min and she said she said she'd
grow like feet I said mom he was born
with that haircut or it's a wig we don't
know Shh it's a wig but it's but it's
don't do one of my favorite they said
that TV show honey booboo and one of my
favorite things they had a store in
their town called it's a wig well Austin
I think that's great man if you can be
that you know if you got that kind of
resiliency and your body and stuff like
that in your body can handle hitting the
water like that dude I remember doing a
60 footer when I was young did you grow
up doing that norm dude I'll tell you
what when I stopped doing it they had a
guy named Jeff in our town who jumped
off of this is probably 95 feet dude off
of an overpass an interstate and hit a
[ __ ] boat he didn't see that a boat
was coming by and fine what happened
right I didn't have that best dude
shattered shattered one of his legs
no lived shattered one of his uh fibulas
or something Tim Ulis and you guys
stopped doing it and he was never the
same
actually he was never the same really
before it I don't think he was never he
was never after he hit that Bodi we all
find a reason after hit that boat you
know now I'm crazy people don't there's
a boat you know and he still went dude
if you do this Husker Tarzan and keep
jumping off the [ __ ] cliffs do it man
yeah this day it's not for me woody
could you do that can you do that yeah
and I see see and you guys think I'm
being mean I don't wanna be racist I'm
just gonna say can you swim I could swim
okay all right I just don't like the
water
oh dude a lot of black guys and they get
in the water they get violent against it
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like they win
the first round that win the second
round - I call it the deep water rap
dude Elijah had to come get me in
Huntington Beach I got stuck
yeah can you swim right now yes man
I'm just curious some guys can't swim D
can you swim you can't swim bro tell me
your bill like my brother he can't swim
we're [ __ ] all right yeah they're
floating [ __ ] is hard it's tough that
doggy paddle is hard
can you swim yeah Jenkins women don't be
like yeah oh wow yeah the only one but
yes women yes what makes this one me son
make me nervous a little bit
I love it man I look like a seal in the
ocean what else we got last 1 boys this
is Aaron Martin from Lexington Kentucky
this is Aaron killer brows hey boys I
have a question for you dating somebody
in law enforcement
oh you a badge bunny King understated
that's a badge bunny does it's a badge
bunny know that little cuff Allah Fergus
oh yeah little bullet bunny up in this
[ __ ] Oh bullet money bro those are
people that get murdered
look at these bullet bunnies her ear
nothing about to sell rabbit meat to
someone all right we call her badge but
law enforcement hey know what you're
signing up for yeah you can see some
Dark Arts and bring it home you know I'm
saying yeah that's what I'm saying man
what'd she say would you go dating
someone in law enforcement King
understand I would date someone in law
enforcement I think oh I'll tell you
this I made love to a girl one time in
Guantanamo Bay and she had a grenade
oh yeah a grenade that she let me hold
you're not talking about her tits are
you no not a real grenade yeah she had a
rule her name the trunk of her car
pretty why why did she have a grenade
you get one dude if you're in the
military
she's in the military yeah yeah oh you
didn't say that sorry
yeah she the military working on
Guantanamo Bay it sounds like you [ __ ]
keep touching me dude get away from me
yeah wait for me you animal yeah yes
badge bunny keep doing your thing we're
gonna press charges against you boy
I mean all of us within the culture
corner brother Oh yep like James Bond Oh
Aloha
yeah good maybe the only thing that it
blasted what else would get oh that's it
boys man
it's good to see you dude yeah man good
to see you too bro see you culture
culture culture culture culture you went
like this a little more my team he big
my team I sound the sidelines during my
college here so I watched a lot to do
Tommy he just gives it you just get it
yeah a lot of steroids on the cute male
cheerleading community where are you
yeah why not you know I am but no
actually you are right you are right
like the dudes that like start and
Jaclyn just live the girls yeah they
yeah they do they called anavar kids hmm
yeah
anavar it's like a type of steroid yeah
I was like what's that word yeah but
yeah I remember and I'm just
I mean I like you cuz you don't see a
real weak guy doing the holding the lady
up they don't let that guy do it Timothy
don't get to do a little timid out there
sharing with ya only the [ __ ] diesel yes
tossing them [ __ ] yeah their words
the diversity I wanna see the guy in a
wheelchair out there you know balancing
her you know doesn't have any feeling in
his arms balance and a check on his head
like a seal yeah one eye out there let's
mix it up yeah yeah you're less out the
cheerleading squads more athletic than
the football team yeah I'll get football
but they'll play the [ __ ] out them drums
yeah you're seeing a movie what drumline
do there's some there's fasiq good
knowledge is uh that they have their
cheer teams they have more titles than
any other thing on the campus like
others all four sheriffís yeah oh you
know what you trying to say is truly do
you know what you're sayin cheerleading
dude what in south it's different it's a
big deal down dude it's a big deal in
the south I hear ya I cheered in Texas
and I cheered it uh Louisville see that
tuck you see that counts that's the
sound did I say you do in California
okay man get more rights as a
cheerleader out here yeah you have more
rights more right you go to a bathroom
you want all right all right
we were travel for games brother I
couldn't get out of the van for like
certain cities yeah there's me why look
at my skin oh we're leaving 1991 you
chilling in Watson well I think you got
some bad Intel man well that's what
coach told me she's gonna get up the van
yeah yeah I think at all I'm gonna come
I'm gonna protect him I got staying up
at night watching the Blind Side on his
phone thank you
I shout out the brushes though yeah what
do you missed out y'all read a Hardy's
British I got the van and [ __ ] got a
biscuit man I used to go to the
boondocks sometimes when I didn't care
you know like I was fine with me
traveling too much maybe it was just
stick up for yourself take a seat in the
front row next from Arizona it No Deal
we do give someday I'd like to track
down your coach have a conversation
where am I gonna be dude I'm coming up
next on the eighth I'm in Cleveland I
believe so I'll let you know that on the
eighth I'm in Cleveland Ohio then and
the ninth I'm in Indianapolis and after
that the 12th I'm in Milwaukee those
places I think still have tickets then
you know Pittsburgh to get some of that
I'll be in Pittsburgh this weekend
actually it's this weekend uh both of
some Pittsburgh brah yeah that's coming
there Thursday Friday Saturday you yeah
I'm in Pittsburgh this week Pittsburgh
improv maybe a link up there we'll see
we'll see let's see we'll see and then
fall on that I think it was Philly is
the 19th through the 21st I'm Philly and
then in November I'm in Dallas and Salt
Lake City
but then I just launched my new tour 50
shades of brown international all over
London Dublin Sweden what about the king
in the sting for that we're supposed to
take place let's do it doggy about who
were just talking about Hawaii but then
you're like no they don't like that out
there no I don't think I don't like it
but I just think we should go there what
comedy but together oh yeah I think we
should go over there there's not a lot
of people like over then do because not
just joke cool
yeah and sounds like 70,000 to you
people loved it man there were so many
people out there were super cool loved
you yes people that were just super
friendly about stuff it was great
nothing better dude so good out back man
got a tan and Hawaiian shirt dude I feel
good love it
Pittsburgh this week Philly next
[Music]